why did you call it a la Baba
Alibaba well when I started I think
Internet is Guillou but we should have a
global name and I named that interesting
like at that time the best ur name is
Yahoo so I've been thinking for many
days suddenly Alibaba is a good night I
happened to being sent San Francisco
that day and I didn't have a lunch and
the waitress can I ask you do you know
about Alibaba should you say yes I see
what is Alibaba she said Open Sesame
good so I went on the street ask about
10 20 people they all know about Alibaba
40 thieves and Open Sesame
and I think this is a good name and
start with a whatever you talk about all
the bubbles on the top when we studied
the e-commerce nobody believed that
China would have e-commerce because
people believe on the one she
face-to-face and all kinds of network in
traditional ways there's no justice
system in China every day we finish more
than 13 minute Ran's actions and that
means that there you are buying things
from somebody you have never seen we are
giving products to the person you have
never met and there are some guys you
never know that he's going to take your
products to that place to that person I
want to tell the people that trust is
there you just watch two amazing clips
from Jack Ma take the next three minutes
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]